wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and get some amazing
motivation from dwayne
the rock johnson enjoy
[Music]
if i had to be great at something i
wanted to be great in this world of
hollywood and movie making
and producing an entertainment i had to
commit and like you guys have to commit
obviously you commit to something commit
to the goal
so i quietly retired two years later i
thought what
did i do with my career because my
movies were not doing well
i was written off i was like it was
around 2006 2007. i was like
i left i pulled jim brown i left when i
was on top
like number one in the wrestling
business and i left it was a ballsy
gutsy some call it stupid move
but i had to commit and i had to follow
it was in my gut
and at that time i'll share this with
you guys and will smith is my boy and i
sat down at that time with the agency i
was with
they said what do you want to accomplish
i said i want to accomplish the world i
want the world
and i want i want will smith's career
but and i said i mean this respectfully
because i know he's here at this agency
with us
i want to do it bigger and better
and they looked at me like i had three
heads and they were like
okay but i still stayed
focused and i still had these still put
in the hard work with my two hands
and that's it and that's what it comes
down to with you guys too you know look
i
i appreciate you guys giving me the time
i enjoyed this back and forth rapping a
little bit
but the one thing i do want to leave you
with is as you guys know there's nothing
you can't accomplish
you're going to go on you're going to
become world champions
the key for me well i think one of the
keys is
remember where you came from keep that
in the front of your mind and when
it goes bad and it goes sideways a lot
does you're getting booed out
building or you're coming through this
injury or people are you writing you off
oh you guys ain't you know any of that
you gotta you gotta keep it in here
and it really has to it should drive you
it should it works for me it should
drive you you get all the talent in the
world it's all here
it's all here everybody's the next best
thing everybody's the thing everybody's
the best
i remember i had great angst
every night before i went out because i
was not able to be myself
my very first wrestlemania the biggest
show of the year the super bowl
uh of wrestling
that night 20 000 fans started chanting
rocky sucks
it was a sobering moment and that was
the beginning of the end
of my initial run in the wwe
a few weeks later um i tore a tendon
into my knee
and i was out for the rest of the summer
and i came to the realization before i
went back
that it wasn't me personally that they
didn't like
it was that i wasn't being me
i wasn't being real i wasn't being
authentic who is this guy
in wrestling who's smiling when he's
getting beat
a few weeks later i got a call from the
wwe and i spoke to vince mcmahon
he said when you come back we could
continue to
shove you down people's throats or we
could turn your heel because they want
to boo you anyway
i said i think it's a great idea and i
said before we get off the phone i run
requests
i said when i come back and we go live
[Music]
i just need two minutes live
me talking to the audience live two
minutes is all i'm asking
he said okay you got it a couple weeks
later i came back we were on live tv
i grabbed the microphone fans were
already booing they started chanting
rocky sucks in arenas across the country
i heard chants of rocky sucks
[Applause]
i said um i may be a lot of things
[Applause]
in that moment the rock was born
and about a month later
i was the hottest heel in the company
and things were on fire
and the greatest lesson about that is
be you be yourself
whether it's in entertainment whether
it's
out in public whether you're celebrity
or not
whatever and the most powerful thing you
can be is yourself
at this point in your career when most
people would be like hey
get those cameras away i don't want to
talk to anybody every single day
you're talking to the people why is that
it's the most important relationship i
have
wow is with the people as i reached a
point in my career i was tired of trying
to be something i wasn't wow so i was
told at that time
listen you can't talk about wrestling
you can't go by the rock you can't be as
big you can't yeah it was a lot of
things like that so finally i reached a
point where i said
all right two things have to happen i'm
gonna surround myself with a different
group of people different management
and um and then i'm gonna make sure that
uh that i just gotta be me
right right me and if you wanna call me
rocky call me rock all right i'm gonna
get it because you didn't know because i
was like i should have come
no yes of course no more rocks no it's
always rock
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
designed a special
free training to help you get it where
every day for the next 254 days i will
send you
a link to an unlisted video to your
email
to every day shift your confidence and
self-belief forward
the science says it can take up to 254
days
of consecutive action to make a habit
stick
and i want you to get the habit of
self-confidence and self-belief
the link to join absolutely for free is
in the description below
my call time is at seven then you
back your clock up four hours and then
that's when i get up be you
be yourself whether it's in
entertainment
whether it's out in public
whether you're a celebrity or not
whatever
and the most powerful thing you can be
is yourself getting up at four o'clock
in the morning every day
before anybody else and grounding my
thought process
is in the no one will outwork me
when it comes to kindness or being nice
it's very very easy
for me i heard something when i was 15
years old i'll never forget it and
this was at a time where we were
struggling to pay the rent and
living paycheck to paycheck and the
quote that i heard was
it's nice to be important but it's more
important to be nice and i remember
hearing that i thought man i hope one
day
maybe fingers crossed god willing
universe willing
whatever that i'm uh considered
important that it would matter if i'm
nice to people so
yeah it's very very easy and also
you know life is much easier when you're
nice and you're not fully
i wrestle john cena and i went in i
think it's 2013
i went in wwe champion and uh
we went and met life stadium we
we had a record-breaking attendance
which was amazing that night
we accomplished our goal so i wrestled
with john cena we had 45 minutes planned
for the match
it's non-stop and go right so your
conditioning is tested
we get to metlife stadium it's a big
night this is it it's game night right
it's it's championship night for me
45 minute match planned out there's no
cut
there's no all right well let's pick it
back up tomorrow you know it's go time
it's just like you guys in a game
at the 15 minute mark bang
i feel something pop i'm like boom
laying there and both of us are out
i said something's going on
and uh i stick my hand that was 85 000
people right and we're just
laid out like this i kind of roll over i
stick my hand down in my trunks just to
see i want to make sure that there was
no bone sticking out
so there's no bone sticking out what
something just happened referee comes
over and he's like rocky all right i'm
like yeah yeah
yeah i think i'm all right i said
i get up i go to step and i
can't i can't do this
i have to use my leg like momentum i
gotta do that
so now in that moment and you guys are
gonna have these moments you probably
already had them already where you're in
the game and you're in the thick of
things
and you got to make a decision what i
got to do i'm going to stay in the game
committed to the team i committed to my
team the entire roster
right in the world of wrestling
when you have a big show like this and
you have a big main event that the
entire show is based around
the wrestlers will come up to the two
people in the main event at some point
all throughout the night in the locker
room and just be like hey
thank you for the house i appreciate it
thank you for the house and what
that means is that's their way of saying
thank you
for drawing helping draw 85 000 people
and putting a lot of
money in my paycheck in my bank account
thank you for the house we got a lot of
thank you for the houses at night
bang this happens and now i realize i
can't move my leg and i got 30 minutes
left of this match
and it's not just like around i mean
these are like
we got to put on a show there's a lot of
big flying and suplexes and all that
so i could tell the rest of us are you
okay and i have one moment in this
moment it was a defining moment i could
either tell him
no i'm done he give the signal
match is over or let's keep going
and again this is a little takeaway for
you guys if you ever have this moment
i'm sure you have
if you haven't it's coming we have this
decision
i said no let's keep going i said how
much time is up he's like 32 minutes
okay wrestle the whole match
couldn't move doing everything like this
i'm getting scared because i'm thinking
man well what happens if i if i if i
pinch something or something like you
know i don't know your mind starts
working with you in the moment there's
85
000 people your adrenaline is rushing
like man what happens if i'm going to
lose my leg or something
like this if i've just done something to
my artery
final move of the match is his big
finishing move and i remember
i'm getting up and i'm turning like this
because i have to fall into him he's
going to hit me with his big finishers
it's like a massive suplex where i go
over his head and
slams me down and i remember turning
i remember turning into john and he says
and i remember thinking to myself
god please don't let this be too bad
just take care of me
take care of me bang
i feel boom
i don't know what just happened now
luckily match is over he pins me one two
three
comes in the back i get to the back i
can't move now i'm
getting a little nervous and um
doctors come in john comes in you're
okay
he comes in we always like to celebrate
with booze he brings like moonshine like
legit moonshine that's like crazy white
boy that they bring
like in a jar this is moonshine hey
let's have some moonshines okay
don't know what's happening rush uh get
on a jet
rushed home to my doctor's down in
florida
and uh get an mri find out that i have
completely torn
my adductor the top of my my adductor
and my top of my quad
off my pelvis yes really really
so it's a very long story to tell you
what i was proud of
was to walk out on my own but not only
that but in this
moment where the odds are against you
people are watching your team's
depending on you you either say i'm done
or this whatever the [ __ ] is going on
it's temporary and it made me up
at some point down the road
but i'm not going to let this
opportunity go by without giving it
mile i wanted to entertain when i was
eight years old i thought i was a
combination of these guys i thought it
was a combination of
chuck norris richard pryor harrison ford
and rocky balboa and harrison ford from
indiana jones i was like
all these guys uh in my oh and elvis
presley two
at eight right i already love the
ambition yes exactly
uh so i knew at that time when i was
eight i wanted to be
an entertainer and i loved the idea of
that and what it meant
um and when i was eight i saw uh indiana
jones for the first time and i
love that character like wow that guy
was so heroic and
he kicked ass i get up super early uh
generally i have this thing where i like
beating the sun up not just in terms of
before the sun comes up i have to get up
and uh how do i do it it's just
important to find balance and i try and
do things really that
i really enjoy doing and a lot of times
you know it's like in life right
life brings like drama and you got to
deal with this person and the
funky relationship here and all these
things you try and just kind of balance
them out as best i can i got a great
team around me by the way
who really really helps me well and
helps me allows for me to come in
and work 12 hours a day 14 hours a day
get up at 3 o'clock in the morning
uh send out an instagram video where i'm
talking to my cardio machine like a
crazy maniac
so yeah it requires a lot of people
around me when i was 15
my dad was wrestling in nashville
tennessee
i moved with him and when my mom finally
arrived in nashville
she had just driven all the way across
country from california and
i knew that my parents were going
through some some really tough times in
terms of their marriage
and it was it was that was a tough day
i'll never forget it it was probably
about one o'clock in the afternoon
we were at a restaurant the three of us
and they they got into it they got into
a very big fight not physical
but just really loud arguing and um
my dad had a car at that time and so
they got into that car
my dad was driving my mom was in the
passenger seat
and i get in the car that my mom just
drove
the family car and i started driving it
i already had my license at that time at
15.
and we're driving down i-65 i-65 is a
major in a state that runs through
tennessee
and i'm watching them drive in front of
me and their car starts swerving and i
can clearly see that they are arguing
my old man makes a hard right and he
gets on the shoulder
and uh in the gravel road
[Music]
my mom gets out of the car and when she
got out of the car
i'll never forget that she had a glazed
look over her eyes that i had never seen
before
and she walks right into the middle of
i-65
and continues to walk down into
oncoming traffic and my heart stopped
horns were blowing and cars were
swerving out of the way
18 wheelers were swerving out of the way
and i got out of the car
and i grabbed her and
wrestled her over to the side of the
road
and
[Music]
i don't remember what i said to her i
remember she didn't say a thing
and in that moment one of the greatest
lessons i've ever learned
was how precious life is and how
in an instant it can all go away
change me the irony is
my mom has no idea that it even happened
that's the irony that's also the beauty
of it she does not remember
anything thank god because
maybe it's too traumatic to remember we
all go through this
and we all lose loved ones is i think
what i've realized in the past couple of
weeks is it's good to explore these
feelings i'm
feeling a little guilty and i didn't get
a chance to say the things that i wanted
to say or i wish
he would have said the things to me yes
as a father
now as a father of three daughters um
the important critical things that
anchor us
that i didn't get from him and it's okay
to explore those feelings but it's also
very important
to heal to make sure that we come back
to an anchoring um foundation
of um of gratitude
and gratitude for the for what i was
able to have with him
yeah you know and so i didn't get a
chance to say the things that i wanted
to say to him
um however another thing that is
important too
is you know because in death that's when
we can spiral
and think well i should have done this
and i should have called and i should
have sent more pictures
but we got to realize that
um the relationship that i had with my
dad
was a relationship that was in that was
appropriate
at that time absolutely up a weight when
i was 14 years old
uh because all the men who i looked up
to in my life
who i aspired to be were all men who
went to the gym picked up iron and took
their business with their own two hands
and they made something of themselves
and of course yes at 14 years old like
everyone in this room
at 14 years old i wanted to be a success
but in my head i thought oh well i'm
going to be a success
i'm happy to put in the park so i went i
put in the work at 14 years old i went
right to wolves gym in honolulu hawaii i
took 135 off and yes
took 135 pounds off that bench and i got
fair
but
i always tell people yes i get up at
crazy hours whether it's three o'clock
in the morning by the way when we were
talking in london i was getting up at
three because i had to be on set by four
i'm sorry by seven so whatever time my
call time is
and i tell this to studios and directors
and our producers whatever time i call
time so my call time is at
seven then you back your clock up four
hours and then that's when i get up and
i train twice i'll get my cardio in and
breakfast and then i'll go
hit the weights clanging and banging we
call it
jack and iron but like what time do you
go to bed i mean you might shoot really
late at night
i'm averaging on a movie on average
probably about five hours of sleep
i found that with depression one of the
most important things you could realize
is that you're not alone
you're not the first to go through it
you're not gonna be the last to go
through it and oftentimes
it happens you just you feel like you're
alone and you feel like it's only you
and you're in your bubble and and i wish
i had someone
at that time who
who could just pull me aside and hey
it's gonna be okay it'll be okay
so i wish i knew that just gotta
remember
hold on to that fundamental quality
of faith have faith
and on the other side of your pain
is something good after
about a month and a half of
staying in that little apartment and
cleaning i got a phone call from the
head coach
of the team who cut me the head coach of
the calgary stampeders he called me and
he said hey
i know we cut you but i'd like you to
come back i said okay i appreciate that
coach thank you very much uh
think about it he said okay great i hung
up the phone and um
my dad said you're gonna do it right i
said
no i don't think so i think i'm done
with that and he goes what i said my gut
tells me
i'm done he said what are you gonna do
i took a deep breath i said i'd like to
get into the business
he said what business i said the
wrestling business
he said you are throwing it all away
it is the worst mistake you will ever
make
he said you're ruining your career i
said maybe i'll be no good
but i feel like in my heart i have to do
this
and i either need you
to train me or need you
to not train me my dad rose to the
occasion
he said i'll train you and it wound up
being
one of the greatest chapters in my life
i knew i wanted to be something and it
was important to me to be something it
was
it was important to me that i didn't
fail but by the way and if i did fail at
least
what was also important was a lesson and
i didn't realize that until i got
older because you know when you're in it
you're in the grind you don't really
recognize those things
uh when you're younger but i could
recognize them now and the importance of
them now and just in terms of the drive
and the determination
um a lot of it was experience too
get your ass kicked you get back up and
you put the gloves back on and you swing
away
when i was 16 years old that was the
last time that i was arrested and at
that time
we were we were at an all-time low i
think with our family and at that time
we were living in bethlehem pennsylvania
and i am already a pretty big boy
six foot four 200 and maybe 20 25 pounds
i had a very bad mustache i had a chip
on my shoulder fresh into this high
school in bethlehem pennsylvania freedom
high school
i wanted to use the bathroom but i
didn't want to use the regular boys
bathroom because the boys bathroom
smelled like smoke and
all the other fun stuff that boys
bathrooms smelled like so i'd go into
the teacher's lounge and
a teacher comes in his name is jody
swick tough guy
he says hey you can't be in here i kind
of pause
look over my shoulder okay
i'll leave when i'm done and i continue
to wash my hands
i slowly uh dry my hands and i walk by
him and i kind of just looked at him
i walked by he looked at me didn't say
word but he was fuming
i went home that night and i felt bad i
just felt
bad very next day
i found him and i went to see him in his
class and i said um
i said i just want to apologize for
how i acted yesterday and
i'm sorry and i stuck my hand out and he
looked at my hand
and looked at me looked at my hand again
he shook my hand
i'll never forget that shake he wouldn't
let it go
he said i want you to do something for
me yes
why don't you come out and play football
for me i said
okay i said all right have your word
yeah
sure you got my word i didn't think much
of it i thought okay
yeah play some football like playing
football sure
cool and i went out nice and i played
football for for jody swick
and he was our head football coach and
um
he became a a father figure to me and a
mentor
i fell in love with the game of football
my grades got better
and i started getting recruited from
every college across the country
college coaches will come in you say
there is
dwayne johnson 64250
both sides of the ball very aggressive
my thought process started to change
that's when i started thinking about
goals and
what i wanted to accomplish and i love
that man
i'll never forget the impact that he had
in my life and
the reminder and my takeaway from that
amazing relationship that i had
was the empathy that he had for a punk
kid who treated him so rudely and
disrespectfully
he looked past that
and said i believe in you and i want to
turn you around
oftentimes when i see kids and they have
been labeled all their punk kids
true but there's good in them
and we got to see that potential and i
enjoy that today seeing the potential in
kids just like
he did especially kids who are kind of
wayward
and have been going through it i know
what it's like
um so thank you jody i'm not working out
i'm not lifting i'm not sweating
[Music]
i'm building
building a foundation
i'm building habits by
breaking
breaking barriers records
[Music]
stereotypes
i'm breaking step
and breaking myself down we all are
if we're doing it right
because when you build yourself back up
that's when you break through training
in some sort of physical activity
becomes my anchor every day
try and stay focused for me i got to get
up at 3 45 in the morning
i do my cardio i'll have my breakfast
then i'll go train and hit the iron
then i'll go to set if i can get those
things done before i go to set then i
could work for the next 12 14 16 hours
you are known as one of the nicest most
pleasant people in show business
but you're also a really big boss that
gets a lot of things done so how do you
balance
being nice and having to lay the
smackdown
there's a few things i always try and
find make sure that i find time every
day to be grateful for everything that i
have when you start off our days finding
things to be grateful for it inevitably
leads to a greater happiness so every
day i wake up i'm a grateful man for
everything that i have
but i'm also very quick to make sure
that
when something needs to get done and you
have to
either articulate it to somebody else
and you have to set a protocol and you
have to set parameters and you have to
lay the smackdown you got to do it in a
firm way
i do it a kind way but i also do in a
firm way and
when it comes to laying the smackdown if
anybody's rude or if anybody is treating
other people rudely
or unkindly i'll happily step
in and they don't want any bit of this
all right don't let this smile fool you
because this is 260 pounds i've kicked
somebody
around here film has the gives me the
biggest opportunity to make the biggest
impact
global impact i don't
want to make small movies i love and
respect our movie business but i want to
make
big movies that do well and when they do
well
it's not the money thing because we have
money right money's good
money's good it ebbs and flows it's the
idea that i can impact as many people as
possible
with a big global movie and when the
global movie is touching a billion
dollars
that sounds good right it's good for the
bank account it's good for everybody
involved everybody's getting their piece
of cake it's great
but what that does do it i know i'm
impacting people around the world
by giving them some good entertainment
making them feel good when i was
15 or 16 years old i went on an audition
for um
for soap opera and i forgot which one it
was
i drove to new york we're downtown and i
read for it and i had no acting
experience at all
i probably got through
four lines before they had said
uh that's fantastic but you know what i
think we're going to go in a different
direction
thank you very much and i was like okay
great but i did great
you know i was very genuine did i do
good i wanted feedback
and they were like yeah sure no you did
you did great absolutely
uh somebody get that cardboard box and
just set it here because it probably
just the same
and then i had another audition with
steven summers that was my big audition
for the mummy returns i had one line in
the movie and that wasn't even english
it was
egyptian dialogue it was akumashentay
and i'll never forget it it probably
means are you silly enough to actually
say these lines and then i
was at that time who inspired you the
most in your life
great question i think that i've been
really lucky
and fortunate to have a lot of people in
my life who's who have inspired me over
the years
i can pull in inspiration from everybody
who i have around me
uh whether it's family whether it's
employees or team members
but you know what it sounds incredibly
cheesy to see a cheese
graphic come in right here the fans
really inspire me
and that is the truth i meet fans all
over the world and
i often say that i have the greatest
fans in the world and i honestly believe
that
fans family team members they all
inspire me
i know you didn't grow up with a lot of
money and i read the story about when
uh i think you were around 15 and there
was an eviction notice on the door
and how that was made a big impression
on you
right it did now yes now you're one of
the highest paid actors
in the world oh thank you
i do all right thank you you do all
right and
does does that title the sexiest man
alive the highest paid and the
although do all of those do the what do
those titles mean
if anything you're the greatest you're
the most popular you're the most
followed you're the most you're the most
the most the most
it's great for the ego it's wonderful
kidding
yeah the better question is how do you
keep your ego in check when all of that
is happening
around you yeah very important um people
i have around me
and how important that is do you have
anybody who can tell you the truth at
this point
yeah she's called my wife yeah okay okay
lauren can tell you this yes
lauren can tell me the truth but by the
way and this is where it's the tricky
thing for us too being in this position
is we want to make sure that we have
people around us who
are inspired to do well and reach for
and continue to share our vision
but also at times say well i'm not quite
too sure if that's the right thing to do
so i look i've had a wonderful career
especially coming from being evicted
and those titles are nice and everything
is fine but i
honestly i you know the i'm
so grateful to be in the position of men
um and i never take anything for granted
i try
aren't you glad that you were once
evicted because it gives you
such an appreciation for what you have
now
it just gives such perspective when we
were 14 years old we lived in hawaii
and we lived in a small efficiency
apartment and we were
my mom and i came home and i'll never
forget the rent was 180
a week and there was an eviction a week
and there was an eviction notice on the
um on the door
and it was this was the one it was the
final
eviction notice like that's the one my
mom started crying
and i never forgot in that moment it was
a seminal moment for me because i felt
like
i never want to be in this position
again what can i
do so at 14 years old i thought well
the heroes in my life muhammad ali for
example
professional wrestlers um they're all
men who have worked hard with their
hands and they built their body
ah yes that's what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna do what my dad taught me and these
other heroes i'm gonna go build my body
so we're never evicted again but being
evicted by the way
has as you were saying has not only
given me just great perspective
but also great gratitude but also
and my team and my family we laugh at it
but i
feel this way like oh well you know
we're we're a month away from being
evicted i got to go to work like i still
have that in my mind i still have that
i still have that in my head you know
where it but it keeps you grounded by
the way
yeah yeah because i that's why the
the most this and the most that again
it's wonderful
but the alternative is what i once was
i read that your father you used to
watch him in training and he would say
if i'm going to get up at 6 a.m you're
going to get up at 6 a.m
so what do you think you got the most
from him was it your work ethic what was
it
it was definitely my work ethic my dad
was a man who
who um against the odds made it
and um but he would get up at usually 5
5 30 in the morning and he would say if
i get up you're gonna get up too
he would drag me to the gym and by the
way i'm five years old and he would drag
me to the gym
yes and i would just i wouldn't work out
but he would just make sure that i was
there
and be with him and that was our time
that we could spend together
and um but i would say my work ethic
from my dad my dad always said to
that regardless of what you do in life
and where you go
respect is going to be given when it's
earned and you have to go out and earn
it
every single day when i was at the the
height of my career in the wwe
i felt that for the very first time that
i was close
to accomplishing everything that i
wanted to accomplish
in wrestling and i quietly
walked away kind of shook me a little
bit because wrestling was all i knew
at that time and i had dabbled in acting
but yet i also felt that i wanted to do
more
and i wanted to achieve more and i
wanted to grow i wanted to grow
as a person i wanted to grow as an
entertainer and that i wanted to reach
as many people as possible not for the
box office value of it
but before the connection and i'd come
from a world
where i was connecting with an audience
every night and i wanted
that connection and i wanted to not only
be
good as an actor but if i made the
transition into acting
i wanted to be great
i knew going in the cards are stacked
against me
there's a shelf life to a career if i
just wanted to get by on
popularity i didn't want to be in that
position
i wanted longevity if that's the goal
then i have to do everything i could
possibly do to know
the business of hollywood from top to
bottom
from acting to marketing to an executive
level
to a producing level to a directing
level
and just know it as a whole that would
inherently
make me a greater asset and
i appreciate all the people in the
beginning of my career
as i was coming up who took the time who
took the effort who took me in
because i had to educate myself and i
had to be a student of the game
know your business know your business
become a student of the game and
surround yourself
with brilliant people and go to work
so before a big movie comes out
before back in the days when i was
wrestling with wwe
a wrestlemania match anything big that
would happen
i would always take a moment and i just
remind myself
all right i was evicted when i was 14.
we were kicked off the island we
couldn't live in hawaii had no place to
live
a lot happened when i moved to nashville
i was arrested multiple times by the
time i was 16 years old
like i remember that um if i were
playing on this team
uh which might you know my skills are um
what's that term oh
so i'll never play but before i lace up
before i get on court before i play in
these big games before i go to the
staples center where
history is there's those are those are
historic walls there at the staples
center
uh i would remember that and it allows
me then to be present in the moment and
understand holy
the stuff i have around me right now
this is that i dreamed of when i was a
kid
what helps me is to keep the hard times
in the front of my mind
because it allows me to go into these
big moments that i've worked my ass off
and you guys have worked your ass off it
allows me to go into these big moments
with a different perspective i was
evicted when i was 14 years old
and then we were forced off the island
of hawaii to move of all places we had
to move to nashville
and we lived in a little motel and i was
trying to remain as positive as i could
and now your company is called seven
bucks why is that seven bucks so my goal
was to play in the nfl and that didn't
happen for me uh
i went up to the canadian football
league i played up there
i got cut from there flew back down to
miami my old man was living in tampa
and i said i called him at midnight when
i landed i said you got to come get me
on the way back up to tampa i said god
you know let me see how much money i got
i pulled out my wallet i opened it up i
took out a five
a one and change and that's why
we have seven bucks making the
transition into hollywood
there was no blueprint before me so it
wasn't like i
i can say oh
there's that other black samoan wrestler
who was like over six four and weighed
whatever pounds
there was a time where i just i was
still trying to find my footing in
hollywood and still trying to understand
how i fit into this machine
and i was enamored and motivated by
the opportunity to play on a platform
that
i hadn't before and coming from the
world of wrestling which was a very
crazy wild world of wrestling
so there was a time where i was a little
concerned with how i fit in
and also if i was even going to fit in
but yeah years later i'm
very fortunate to be sitting here now
[Music]
i feel like for me it feels
seamless because you prepared for so
long but it's just like you guys
prepping for a game
that's the fun part that's where it's
like it's fun man people are paying
their hard-earned dollars to come see
you
they're cheering they're going bananas
they're booing it out of you or on the
road
it's that's fun that's what you live for
i mean that's the juice
right there the prep is where the
character is made
and i just don't mean the character i
play i mean the character in here
so for me the prep is getting with the
director getting with the producers
getting with the writers getting with
the getting with so in essence it's like
getting with all your coaches and your
different uh position coaches and and
all the
meetings that you have to have right so
that's the work you put in
the key for me was
where does it start what's the anchor
what's the anchor so i could have all
these ambitions and you guys have all
these ambitions which is great
it's important i'll play this role
you'll play that role
i'll execute this thing and it'll come
out this summer you guys will execute
this thing
during the summer right when it's time
to really put in a lot more work
but the key with me is just always
finding what the anchor is and the
anchor is getting up at four o'clock in
the morning every day
before anybody else and grounding my
thought process
is in the no one will outwork me
no one i love and i respect you guys
will not work me all starts with this
two hands putting it to work i think a
lot of people
look up to you in terms of a role model
for achieving your ambitions
sure what is your advice for people
watching this going i want to do that
thing
i love the way that you do this how do i
go about doing it what's your golden
rule
i don't know if there's a golden rule i
can tell you this that
i believe anything is possible right i
live in the world of possibility
and i also believe that anything we can
accomplish anything
with our two hands and just putting in
the work with our two hands and also
you hear this often but it's really
really true you gotta find something if
you love what you do and find and be
passionate about what you do and find
something that you can be passionate
like it really helps you know it gives
you that motivation when you wake up in
the morning
but wait i need one more chance to prove
that i could to be a
maybe greek god because that's my other
favorite part of the film we're kind of
like
is he or is he not exactly i don't know
which i love that's the new take because
you kind of leave it like
believe in yourself that's whether
you're a god or not is just believing in
yourself and embracing
who you were born to be so by the way
like you're biracial and biracial right
on black samoan
black white yeah exactly so oftentimes
hybrids right and oftentimes like when
you're younger
you know we struggle sometimes with
identity i wish i was a little bit more
like that or i wish i wasn't different
but you know overall the message of
hercules how i bring this whole thing
back around
is you are most powerful and most
important is when we just embrace who we
are
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get
motivated inspired you have a 35 chance
of following through but when you get
motivated
inspired and you create a plan of action
you have a
over 90 chance of following through and
when you share with other people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood of
following through and so i want that to
be you
from this video we don't just watch
videos here believe nation we do
something we take action
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you the
training for me has become very defining
has become part of my life
lifestyle it's defined me in many ways
when i was 14 years old i started
training and i thought to myself if i
can
i want to be successful in the way i i
know how to be successful i think are
the men i admire and those men in my
life were
pro wrestlers who were my uncles and my
dad and
then they were also arnold
schwarzenegger and star wars were your
favorite wrestlers when you were a kid
my dad uh rocky johnson my uncle jimmy
superfly snooker the wild samoan
was your uncle yeah
so these men were like big men who
always trained and got
things done with their hands if you want
some more amazing motivation from eric
thomas check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there nothing
impressive happens in gazelle mode
nothing happened when you run it
nothing happened in run mode give up
mode quit mode
scared mode fearful mode nothing happens